my name is Osama Baroni from MB holding
I'm the director for new business
development covering Africa as well as
other places I'd like to reply to mr.
Landry Megan Megan which is basically
about the comment where he'd like to see
or she'd like to see social empowerment
of people so young intrapreneurs social
entrepreneurship people basically making
a difference taking that being empowered
to make a difference to their
communities I see more of more more and
more of that here in Africa and I really
believe that those people would
basically inspire others to actually do
the same and within five years we'd have
a very different Africa